حرب على الفساد ام مذبح امنيه ام تصفيه
حسابات يقودها رئيس الوزراء العراقي
الجديد محمد شع السوداني الذي يظهر او
يظهر فعليا عكس ما يبطن بحسب ما يتهمه
منتقده فقبل انتهاء تحقيقات سرقه القرن
اعلنت الحكومه العراقيه تفكيك اكبر شبكه
لتهريب النفط في البصره جنوب البلاد جهاز
الامن الوطني كشف ان شبكه التهريب التي
يقودها احد التجار
عاليه وموظفين كبار اعتقلوا بموجب مذكرات
قبض صادره عن القضاء لكن كيف يتم التهريب
الامن الوطني ذكر ان شبكه التهريب تقوم
باحداث ثقوب في خطوط تصدير النفط الخام
بحق الزبير النفطي بالارقام كانت الشبكه
تهرب بحدود بين خمسه الى سبعه
ريج بسعه بسعه 50.000 لتر يوميا اي حوالي
75 مليون
شهريا بالعوده الى قضيه سرقه القرن يجري
القضاء العراقي تحقيقات مع متهمين بسرقه
ما يقدر بنحو
2.5 مليار دولار من اموالي هيئه الضرائب
العامه كما اعلن سابقا هذا المبلغ الضخم
جرى سحبه بين سبتمبر من عام 2021 اغسطس من
عام 2022 من مصرف الرافدين الحكومي عبر
247 صكا ماليا وحرره الى خمس شركه قامت
بصرفها نقدا مباشره لكن اثاره قضيه سرقه
القرن بالتزامن مع انطلاقه عمل حكومه
السوداني لم تكن بريئه من حيث توقيتها
بحسب معارضين لا بل ان هنالك مخاوف جديه
من ان تتحول معركه الفساد الى معركه تصفيه
حسابات ويدلل المعارضون على ذلك بالمذبح
الامنيه التي حصلت امس لكن لماذا يشكك
هؤلاء في خطوات السودان البعض ما يزال
ينظر الى السوداني على الشكل الذي اشتهر
به ضمن المالك والمقصد طبعا رئيس الوزراء
العراقي الاسبق ورئيس الائتلاف دوله
القانون نور المالكي ويدفعون بان الحمل
التي يشنها السوداني على اجهزه الامن
والاستخبارات تتخذوا من الحرب على الفساد
ذريعه لتمرير الاقالات الامنيه ويؤمنون
بانها تاتي استجابه لضغوط المالك وزعيم
ميليشيا العصائب قيس الخزعلي لكن من هم
المقالون نتعارف عليهم